an average adult human mouth contains 32
teeth
the agreed definition of a tooth is a
highly mineralized unit within the mouth
32 highly mineralized units eight in
sizes four canines eight premolars and
eight molars
plus four wisdom teeth which don't tend
to make themselves known
until about five years after the rest of
the adult sector in place because of
course these 32 teeth
are your second set an average baby is
born with both milk and adult teeth
already in their head
a seven-year-old indian boy was recently
found to have 526 teeth
inside his mouth but let's stick to the
more common number
20 milk teeth 32 adult a total of 52.
52 teeth rarely visible when born but
they're all there
in the skull waiting waiting
to erupt thank goodness we can't
remember teething
consider if you will the brutality of
these shards of enamel
ripping through innocent gums no wonder
babies cry
reward for this discomforting experience
comes when that first set of baby teeth
start to fall out
ready for the tooth fairy the first
recording of such a transaction with a
fee being paid for a child's lost tooth
is in 13th century norse culture vikings
going into battle would wear necklaces
made up of children's teeth
not because it presumably looked utterly
terrifying but because they were
considered
lucky in the uk the most common price
paid for a tooth is one
pound although eleven percent of
children apparently sleep soundly with a
crisp
fibre under their pillow far less lumpy
than a coin
children in the middle ages were
sometimes instructed to burn their baby
teeth
or risk spending the afterlife searching
for them
with such historical scaremongering
surrounding teeth it is perhaps easier
to understand
why so many people now have a fear of
dentists
84 of all adults in the uk have at least
one filling and the average brit has
seven
of course fillings are just one dental
procedure your teeth may also be clean
flossed capped or crown bonded braced
sealed whitened or extracted
but just remember that going to the
dentist today is far less precarious
than it used to be
before dentistry found acceptance as a
medical profession extraction was the
domain of barbers
and blacksmiths essentially anyone with
access to sharp tools
or heavy pliers as 19th century dentists
like
horus wells and william morton struggled
to be considered professionals rather
than tradesmen
public demonstrations of painless tooth
extractions became more and more
commonplace
some using nitrous oxide ended in a
volunteer screaming in agony but
by 1846 dentistry had finally cracked
anesthesia
people attempt to please their dentist
by brushing their teeth
a practice that has evolved from twigs
and leaves into a global toothpaste
industry
worth billions human teeth are now
primarily used for biting our strips of
sticky tape
but these highly mineralized rocks are
also responsible for crushing slicing
and making manageable almost every meal
or snack you'll ever enjoy
but we also use them to reflect our mood
to others be that
a welcoming smile or an aggressive snarl
contemporary teeth can be adorned with
jeweled grills or filtered to perfection
on instagram but to think of the
all-white uniform smile as perfect is a
relatively
recent obsession having a varied set of
teeth is what allowed humans to survive
and flourish across the globe
our teeth have evolved to incorporate
varying diets and environments
frankly we're lucky to have them
alligator teeth are considered
particularly lucky but if you're seeking
dental inspiration
look no further than sharks
unlike us sharks can afford to lose a
few teeth as they're able to regenerate
and replace them almost continuously
one great white shark can produce tens
of thousands of teeth in their lifetime
which makes our 52 seem relatively
toothless thanks for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video